[Music]
[Music]
valuetainment giving values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we gain no
value to haters how they run homie look
what i become i'm the only one
[Music]
for impact but that is though so folks
first of all um
if you're joining us on today's podcast
i gotta say i applaud you i respect you
i salute you
you are uh part of the community that
likes watching movies such as stigmata
uh maybe exorcist uh maybe the exorcism
of emily rose you're one of those folks
who likes scary movies because i want to
prepare you for today's podcast a
slightly different we're not talking
about current events today
specifically tied to
politics or sports or business or
anything
we are only talking about the topic of
exorcism and the reason why we chose to
do this interview today
and i'll let you know who we have in
house who is a fully qualified exorcist
uh who's been doing this uh since 2005
in 2005 when there were only
12 uh individuals that did this in the
catholic church and today it's at 125.
more than 10x and 17 years if you guys
are looking for a new profession this
profession is growing
rapidly
um but it's gonna be a different kind of
a podcast because we're actually gonna
listen to a few different clips we're
gonna listen to a few
audio clips maybe a video clip
of uh the
real annelise michelle or michael
however you want to pronounce it
on the six different uh voices that she
would make sounds that she would make
one of them being nero fleischmann
hitler lucifer judas and
uh i want to say there's a cain is the
other one that also she made
and uh you know he's going to give us
our feedback in this room just so you
know we have a few people that
don't believe this is real we'll take a
different angle with it to see if he's
going to be convincing or not he seems
like a real convincing man my dad and i
yesterday were up late
he asked me so who do you have on the
podcast tomorrow i said i have an
exorcist on the podcast tomorrow he
starts laughing i said no i'm actually
dead serious he says
what did i tell you about that movie i
said dad i totally understand but i
really am having somebody who's an
exorcist he says in real life i said of
real life
so my dad when he first when i movie
came out a friend of mine fernando lasso
said exorcist is out at chinese theater
so they brought it back in in l.a it was
like 2 000 i think the year was i just
got out of the military and i worked in
a valley tour of fitness he says we got
to go watch it
so we go to watch it and we're in his uh
card that he has he says but there's one
thing we have to do i have a tape that i
brought from
ecuador
where
folks who
you know they were
they would listen to the voice and read
the bible backwards we have to listen to
this audio to put us in the right
setting before we watch this movie so he
puts the tape in no joke
it's me fernando and mauricio we're
listening to this audio tape it's like
love
like stuff like this i said turn the
[ __ ] off you do that very well
and then i'm sitting a little too well
and i'm sitting i'm like so then we go
watch the movie and we're inside
everybody's freaking out in the movie
theater i there's a scene there's the
place is full i pick up my cup
and i just shake it like this because
there's to see if there's any drink left
in it that makes a sound everybody jumps
up
we come out i said listen we're not
going home tonight we went to my
sister's place we stayed up to three
o'clock in the morning talking about the
movie and my dad has his own stories and
everybody has their own exorcist story
the first time they watch it anyways is
your dad going to be watching this
podcast
this may be the first ever podcast my
dad doesn't consume that if you watch
this
i am so proud of your bravery because i
know how you feel about the movie
genghis because in farsi they called
exorcist so anyway he's he's
a very wise man very wise man very well
christian man very christian who
believes in god and evil does he believe
in this kind of well he he is more
leaning towards believing okay he is
more towards he does believe it exists
that's why it makes him a little bit
uncomfortable so look you know we're
going to go through this so let me kind
of give you an idea who our guest is
once again today's father vincent
lampert
who uh has been doing this again since
2005 where there was only 12 of them
he has uh
been on vice he's been on so many
different shows he has uh
done interviews they have spoken to him
about this and you have to keep this in
mind guys it's not like
you know for some folks like it's a
bunch of this is not real all this stuff
this is not a tele-evangelist that goes
on tv like a benny hen or you know a
prosperity pastor that's doing this and
if you give me a million dollars to get
my private jet i'm gonna be able to get
the demons out of you this is not that
model so this is a man that you know we
even pulled up the average salary of a
uh priest a part of the catholic church
who makes 35 to 50 000 you may be at 52
but the the numbers are 35 to 50
thousand dollars we pull up the numbers
we're looking it up so to see the
credibility behind it but once again
with that intro to set everybody up if
you're gonna watch this you can't tell
us you're afraid or upset afterwards i
just prefaced everything we're gonna go
through today so having said that
father vincent lampert thank you so much
for taking the time and being a guest on
the podcast yes i'm happy to be here so
very open-ended question you know
it's a simple question but maybe a
complicated one for us when we kind of
look at you from our perspective
you know some of us wake up we say we
want to be an astronaut you know we want
to be a doctor we want to be engineers
to make our parents proud i want to be a
basketball player i want to be a
baseball player i want to be a
you know hedge fund manager who wakes up
saying one day i want to do
exorcism
like how does that come about
i think i woke up one day and said i
wanted to be a priest okay
but then in the catholic tradition it's
the bishop of every diocese who is the
exorcist because when jesus sent the
twelve out he gave them authority over
every unclean spirit
and then a bishop of a diocese can't
appoint one or more of his priests to do
this ministry in his name
so when i was appointed in 2005 i
jokingly tell people i was in the wrong
place at the wrong time
because you mentioned earlier there were
only 12 exorcists united states back in
2005
the archdiocese of indianapolis where i
am a priest
was a diocese that always maintained
having an exorcist so even when the
practice fell out in many dioceses
across the world
indianapolis decided to always have a
priest in his position
and then ironically the priest who was
the exorcist
he was the pastor of the great school
where i attended
and he passed away in 2005 and then all
the priests we began kind of trying to
stay under the radar so that the bishop
would not appoint us to be the exorcist
but i happen to have a meeting with the
bishop one day and
he said i'm appointing you to be the
exorcist i don't really know what i'm
asking you to do but i'm going to send
you to rome and you can learn
what the ministry is really all about
so when he says that to you were you
like oh my gosh what an incredible
moment of my career you know i'm gonna
get this is so awesome maybe you're
going and bragging to your friends guys
check this out i just got a promotion or
was it more like why are you choosing me
what was your feeling when you got that
call
i think it was the the line of jesus at
the crucifixion my god my god why have
you forsaken me
and really didn't know why the bishop
was selecting me but the church does say
that the priest
should be known for his holiness and
piety
he should have some years of priesthood
behind him so a newly ordained priest
should not have the ministry it should
be a priest who is pretty
comfortable
in his priestly identity
by the which churches practice exorcism
is it just the catholic church or are
other do other religions also practice
exorcism exorcism can be found in just
about every faith tradition whether
christian or non-christian
the belief in the reality of evil
probably the catholic church because
it's uh it's it's a liturgical right for
us so we have a prescribed way of doing
it
so it's probably that most people have
the
concept that catholics primarily do this
but i always say that the catholic
church doesn't have a monopoly on the
practice
but perhaps what the church does is more
widely known by many people but it's
more catholics like i'm pulling it up
right now and it says
catholicism eastern orthodoxy
lutheran churches church of latter-day
saints
you know
but majority of them is catholic church
right if you were to think about
exorcisms am i wrong i may be wrong on
this no i think you're right because
you know i currently get about uh
70 people contacting me every week
from literally all over the world
and about half of them are catholic and
the other half are either other
christian faith traditions or other
world religions or no faith background
whatsoever so i think people have the
mentality that if you're dealing with
the demonic the catholic church as the
ministry of charity
would help anybody who finds himself in
this situation
when you get these calls what do these
calls sound like
i've heard just about everything you can
imagine people that you know us from the
basic one to
the ones where this person needs help we
have to talk to this person
there's a lot of people who believe that
maybe somebody put a curse on them one
of the primary things i try to do is if
it's truly something demonic
then what was the entry point for the
demonic into this person's life the
average person doesn't really have to
worry about
extraordinary demonic activity if one is
living their life the way that they
should
they're pretty much safeguarded but if
somebody does something they could open
up an entry point to the demonic in
their life
they can begin experiencing all kinds of
problems so i tried to determine
what was that entry point what did
somebody do or what did somebody try to
do to them
that brought about the demonic activity
in their life when you say entry point
do you mean physical entry point like
how does the demon enter someone's body
or do you mean more uh esoterically how
do you mean how they initially made the
connection with the demonics like did
somebody dabble when
magic in witchcraft and those types of
things okay and then so the demonic
would look for an opportunity to
literally connect with that individual
in order to try to destroy their life
and then physically how does a demon
enter the body like
through their mouth through their face
through their body through their heart
through their soul how does it actually
happen
not through their soul because the soul
always remains free whenever it's a
question of demonic possession it's
always physical in nature so the devil
would take control of the person's body
treating that body as if it were its own
so using the person's mouth to speak
their ears to hear their eyes to see
and anytime a demon possesses somebody
one should always make the distinction
between that person as an individual
and now the identity of the demon that
is now acting through that person's body
was going to say one could get kind of
heady in the topic saint thomas aquinas
would always say that it isn't literally
that
a demon is inside of somebody it's that
the demon is controlling that person
yeah adam most of the time you'll find
in the in the christian faiths i'm a
born-again christian non-denominational
um so you understand the perspective of
what i share here today
and
it's referred to as ground taken and
ground cancelled and so what ground has
been given in the spiritual life of the
person
that that demon uses as the foothold for
spiritual spiritualization and um
and demonization
uh i i kind of draw the line as many
christian faces do as you know about the
you know
the oppression versus occupation line
you know and so um we see it as
demonetization and heavy oppression
using that ground that that person
has you know um consequentially
you know opened themselves up to
and that ground has to be was there a
statement or a question i'm curious no
that was a statement adam because he
asked a question does it enter through
your mouth or anything like this and i
also
provided a sidebar so that you know
father understands my perspective i got
you perfect so so by the way if you're
listening to this i'm curious do you
believe in in this
or do you not believe in this just
comment below i'm just curious to know
where the audience is at if you say pat
i i do believe in this
give it a thumbs up if you don't believe
in it put a thumbs down tyler can we do
a poll is that possible put a point
yeah i'm actually curious so so let's
continue let's continue with this part
so um when you when you do go to school
because you wrote a book about this i
think there's a book about it right so
the book his name is uh
the uh it's called exorcism the battle
against satan and his demons uh is a
book that you wrote and in the book you
talk about a few different things how
the church selects and trains priests
for the ministry of exorcism where and
how the devil operates in the world
and what scripture had to say about it
why is it vital for catholics to live in
a vibrant uh life of faith what do you
believe what do you do if what to do if
you suspect the president of demonic in
your life
or in others and to fend off spiritual
attack and build a stronger relationship
with god okay so let's talk about you so
when when the when the priest you spoke
to said i want to appoint you to do this
and we have to send you back to rome to
go get trained and come back what did
the training entail
and how long was it
so i stayed in rome for three months in
the early part of 2006.
really the church says the best way to
learn it is through the apprenticeship
model to find a more seasoned exorcist
and then to work under him it's easy to
pick up books and learn what the church
believes and teaches
about the reality of evil
but the church wants its exorcist to
have
kind of literally on-the-ground training
it's kind of like a doctor who has to do
kind of an intern
before one is sent out and begins doing
it on their own
so the internship
when i was in rome i was able to connect
with a franciscan priest who had been an
exorcist for 25 years
and then he permitted me to
sit in on 40 exorcisms that he performed
during the time that i was there and
then that allowed me to learn firsthand
the ministry of the church
for those who were up against the forces
of evil and were seeking help
what was the most extreme one you
witnessed out of the 40 because of
course you get that question all the
time
there are a few that stand out you know
obviously the very first one
you know i'm talking with a uh
an elderly lady and her husband
and she's
explaining to me why she believes that
she's possessed and
you know i i'm just the three of us are
in the room or we're having a
conversation
and i'm watching father carmine the
priest who trained me and he walks into
the room and he puts a roll of paper
towels on the table and he walks back
out and he comes back in and ties a
plastic grocery bag onto the wall
radiator
he walks back out again and he comes in
and this time he has a purple stall
which is a piece of purple cloth that a
priest will drape around his neck as a
sign of his priestly office he has the
right of exorcism in his hand and he
immediately takes holy water and he
blesses this little elderly lady as soon
as the drops of water hit her the demon
manifested her eyes rolled in the back
of her head she began foaming at the
mouth growling and snarling
and throwing out all kinds of
blasphemies
such as
you know she was insulting god she was
insulting me and
father carmine and just about anyone
basically
doing anything as a way to disrupt this
particular prayer of the church
and then you said so you've seen many so
that was the first one you saw was there
anything that was more extreme than her
absolutely
the one that really stands out the most
was uh
during an exorcism when the demon
manifested and the person's body began
to levitate
you saw somebody's body i saw a person
levitate during an exorcism how how much
was a levitation the person rose about a
foot out of the chair they were in
because i'm looking at this in disbelief
and father carmine is praying the right
of the church the prayers and he's
glancing over and looking and he looks
back at his book he looks back at the
person he looks back at his book then he
takes his hand puts it on the head of
the person and pushes them back down
into the chair without ever pausing for
one even one moment
in the prayer was any of that caught on
camera
the church does not videotape oftentimes
how convenient father but let me let me
ask this question but the reason the
church does that is you protect the
identity of the individual
so obviously at this point you know adam
believes in this stuff a lot i am very
skeptical just to put it out there i'd
like to see what the audience is that's
but this mixture of who we have today is
perfect of where i think it's healthy to
be skeptical so you know
if i go to a david copperfield show and
i kind of see you know what the works is
doing i look up i see the strings i'm
like that's pretty cool how they're
doing it but
in this setting when that happened how
many people were in the room when you
saw this
it was me another priest father carmen a
the individual and a family member that
was with him so five of you five of us
so it's not
so here's the part let's play
let's play a skeptic but let's also play
why would he say this so when you look
at him he doesn't look like something
like i watch his interviews
you know there is what is like yesterday
the biggest thing was what's the motive
like when i watch bob larson i'm not
gonna lie i don't know how you feel
about bob larson you look like you have
some opinions on bob larson or no
we all do okay so i'd be curious to get
your feedback on bob larson
and when i rob larson is who exactly
he's uh
famous exorcist do you know who the
daughters is that yeah bob larson's the
guy with the daughters this is bob
larson so yeah i've seen him a guy like
him
is why nobody would believe in exorcism
okay yeah because this is the part where
it's the flamboyant the showmanship the
you know all the stuff i have a hard
time you may what's your opinion on bob
larson before i even go further
well rather than being critical of
someone else i would tend to be want to
be more positive about what i believe
exorcism is because we talked about
skepticism and exorcist is trained to be
a skeptic
i should be the very last person in the
room to believe that somebody is truly
dealing with extraordinary demonic
activity every other possible
explanation needs to be exhausted and
that's the approach the catholic church
takes that's why even in the united
states we have a protocol that we follow
and step number one of the protocol is
for the person to have a psychiatric
evaluation step two is to have a
physical examination because the church
wants experts in the mental health field
and in the medical sciences to weigh in
on what is happening or what this person
believes is happening in their life
i will say because i am publicly known
as an exorcist
i receive the high volume of people who
reach out to me but the majority of the
people who reach out to me have already
self-diagnosed
and any exorcist will tell you that when
somebody has self-diagnosed
99 of the time it's not something
demonic
99 of the time it's not something that's
more like the id or it's something else
that uh absolutely yes okay when someone
self-diagnoses meaning they think that
they are possessed by a demon
99 percent of the time they it's not
accurate correct okay so they're they're
calling me and saying i'm possessed that
i need an exorcism and my response would
be
no you're not we may get to that point
yeah but we have to look at what is
actually wrong with them at that point
they're schizophrenic they're bipolar
they're on drugs their depression what's
the what's the it could be all of those
and that's why it has to be
investigated because i would be the
first one to say the church would do
greater harm to uh to someone if she
labels that person as being possessed
and that label prevents the person from
getting the true help that they need so
there may be other people that are
exorcist that may be too quick
to believe
that somebody is possessed but again i
think that would do greater harm
if it prevents them from going and
getting help from
the psychiatrist or their family doctor
because the overriding goal should be to
get
help and for the person who is suffering
whether that be due to spiritual
physical or mental problems that they're
having in their life
i don't wanna i don't wanna hover over
this i think tom wants to say something
then i wanna go back to the levitating
and bob larson go ahead do you also
conduct a spiritual inventory like take
them to galatians and go through the
list of things so you're satisfied that
there's a psychiatric evaluation which
is prudent a physical evaluation looking
for signs of drug use and other things
are very obvious in the physical realm
you know
and then
do you take them to a spiritual
inventory yes so there is that's step
three of the protocol
there is an intake questionnaire that
was you know the vatican has a
course on exorcism every year and a part
of that
they helped put together an intake
questionnaire trying to determine if
this truly is something demonic
then what opened the doorway for that
into the person's life and then it's not
only then identifying
it's also about helping the person
resume their spiritual life
or to start a spiritual life for the
first time so it's not just a matter of
casting demons out god has to be invited
in and i would say that in the role of
an exorcist the primary focus is not
really on what the devil is doing in the
person's life
but what god wants to do in that
person's life
and there are four different types of uh
things that the church looks for
that would validate that perhaps is
truly a something demonic number one
would be the ability to speak and
understand languages otherwise unknown
to the individual
having superhuman strength beyond the
normal capacity of the individual having
elevated perception knowledge about
things that the person should not
otherwise know
and then four probably the one that most
people are familiar with an aversion to
anything of a sacred nature such as
having scripture read in front of them
being blessed with holy water being
shown a crucifix the things that people
probably are familiar with simply by
watching movies and whatnot on exorcism
so so the four things was superpower a
language that they should not speak
access to in formation that they
normally shouldn't have and then the
fourth one is what the priest does or
them like how they respond to holy water
uh aversion to anything right spiritual
um in the christian church and um are
you familiar dr carl payne
no i'm not no you know carl payne wrote
a a wonderful book on uh spiritual
warfare from non-denominational
christian perspectives so it doesn't
contain anything like from the
presbyterian or the southern baptist
convention it's just non-denominational
bible interpretation and one of the
things he pointed out was that something
as simple as reading first john 4 and
saying you know every
this is how you recognize the spirit of
god you know every spirit that
acknowledged that jesus christ has come
into flesh is from god every spirit that
does not acknowledge jesus christ is not
and
people have a strong resistance to that
those particular verses that are that
are calling on that with the power
and
you know
when
helping people
with demonization
it's exactly as you say
and but you can avoid you can avoid the
sensational reaction of them by setting
ground rules and asking for the covering
of the holy spirit have you ever
witnessed this before i've not witnessed
this before but i've talked to three
people that that um
have you ever had anybody in your life
what but this goes to all of the tyler
this goes to you and to you have you
guys ever seen anybody in your life
where you said this person may be
possessed yeah absolutely you've had
somebody yes absolutely and you
witnessed it like you you knew this
person or was it a person that person
knew it was my friend's mom and i i
witnessed her in a
and she was not drugs she was in hospice
but she was not being given morphine or
anything of the of the sort so she was
unmedicated have you witnessed anybody
yeah it just turns out that they were on
bath salts okay how about yourself no no
you never have okay so so i have
witnessed a close relative
that would say i put a curse on that
person okay
i put a curse on that person and watch
what's gonna happen to that person and
i've seen a person
behavior
act in a weird way but my my opinion on
that is a completely different thing
which we'll get into here in a minute i
want to go back to this so people like
bob larson are are who pushes me away
from believing any of this stuff is real
and they're using it to monetize and
sensationalize and get eyeballs people
like you don't do that to me because
there is no motive for you to do this
why would you do this i don't sit there
and say your motivation is that
why do you say there's no motive though
but for him right for him i don't so
okay let's go through the motives of
life what are the main motives of life
or why somebody would deceive you why
somebody would deceive you money is
number one what else what's another
motive status status somebody to have
sex with you right to kind of like
impress you where you're like hey oh my
gosh and then boom take advantage okay
what else is it what else is a motive
recognition recognition fine but that's
still okay what else would it be what
else would it be so what what else would
the motive be here that's the part even
something bigger than themselves i.e the
catholic church i mean you got a lot to
answer to if you're i do if you're going
to answer to the church i'm not saying
anything about the father but
you know there's a hierarchy up there at
that part i understand that part i
understand and we'll get to that here in
a minute but let's go back to it so when
you saw this person levitate a foot
and there's only five of you in the room
what's your initial reaction what's your
first reaction
disbelief
disbelief
that was my initial reaction but then i
quickly focused
on what the priest who was training me
was doing
because he wasn't focused on
the theatrics of the demonic if you will
he was staying focused on the prayer of
the church which is why he was able to
simply reach over put his hand on the
head of the person put him back
push him back down into the chair
why would he push him down if someone's
gonna levitate i'd like to see how high
they go up why
why clip the angel's wings so to speak
let them let's see how high they can go
up you're up a foot yeah but let's stay
serious here but i'm not i'm being
actually very serious someone is out of
time
super loud though if someone is is full
on levitating
let them levitate
yeah i mean so okay so but the reason i
think that that he did not let him do
that because that allows the demonic to
be in charge of the prayer that's taking
place and again the focus should always
be on what god is doing because the
demonic obviously would want to disrupt
the prayer because it wants to maintain
its connection or hold on the life of
this individual right and what the
priest is doing invoking the power and
the authority of god and that's the
other important thing to make to point
out i don't have any special powers and
abilities if people are relying on me
we're all in trouble but if people are
relying on the power and the authority
that christ has given to the church
that's the proper mentality to have so
it's not about me and any power that i
have even the priest who trained me told
me he says if you're ever doing an
exorcism for and even for a brief moment
think wow look at what i'm doing he said
you've just walked on unholy ground
exactly that's the uh that's the story
of the seven sons of skeva the seven
sons of skiva were going out attempt and
they were doing minor
minor illness healings correct um by
invoking the name of jesus christ until
they came up to a truly oppressed person
and the person
says jesus i know
and says and paul i've heard of but who
are you remember that and the individual
beat these people
individually and and paul
pointed out he said look you know these
people were not authentic this is a sham
and it's it's like benny hinn a faith
healer with a toupee exactly and that's
kind of like what bob larson seems like
to be and so so here's here's where i go
with this you know the the saint the
second is the the the quote by charles
uh baudelaire okay i don't know how to
pronounce the guy's last name the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world he didn't exist
okay
then uh can usual suspects yeah exactly
ken army says the second greatest trick
the devil a devil ever pulled was
convincing the world he is a good guy
okay
and then i read a book called tom put
your phone aside because it's picking up
some of the static so the the other
thing that that the the
uh what do you call it a quote i read in
a book called um
what's the book's name the outwitting
the devil i don't know if you've ever
read the book outwitting the devil it's
a form of screwtape letters by c.s lewis
it's some kind of a book like that
and in this book it says
you know the greatest trick the devil
ever pulled is convincing you that he
existed
okay
so
when you when you hear and you know what
the difference is obviously the
difference between so the argument on
one side is what he doesn't exist dude
just go do whatever you want to do just
live your life and be free and have you
know that whole thing have fun who cares
you only got one live you know
what is that one acronym yolo hey you
only live once and go do whatever you
want to do that's okay great
but in a way
the other quote says live as as if you
know
you know the greatest trick he ever
pulled is to convince you that he exists
he doesn't exist it's just a pigment of
your imagination you
it's in your thoughts it's your
imagination when you hear those two
arguments what's what do you say to that
well it sounds like the the devil wants
to be the one that dictates everything
and i think there's too much focus on
on the devil
there's too much focus on the devil
absolutely do you think one has to if
one believes in god do they
automatically have to believe there's a
there's a devil
there's a song that i'm thinking about
what is it blood sweat and tears 1969 i
swear there ain't no heaven but i pray
there ain't no hell
is that oftentimes people
won't believe in god
but then there's that fear of kind of
the unknown and the demonic can be that
fear of the unknown and that's where the
devil can try to get into people's heads
and whatnot
is there an official stance from the
catholic church regarding the devil
yes so the church would say that that
evil is personified so evil is not just
humanity's inhumane treatment of one
another it's not just something of our
making
but the that
evil is personified in what we call the
devil
and his demons so who is the devil who
are his demons the book of revelation
speaks about the fall of the angels
where lucifer
rebelled against god and then one third
of the angels fell and were cast down to
the earth
so evil is personified and then what
would be the goal of the devil and these
demons is to get humanity to make the
same choice that they made which would
be
the complete rejection of god can i
can i
[Music]
push back a little bit and just
challenge and let's just have some fun
with this
uh and this is purely the skeptic side
where you know one would be skeptic and
saying you know what they say to this
when i was an atheist and i was going
through meeting with everybody i'd meet
with scientologists i'd meet with
priests i'd meet with pastors that me i
wanted to meet the person that says hi
this guy knows everything about the
bible you got to me i wanted to meet
those types of people and i would go
through my arguments and now
you know many of my arguments were
amateurish arguments and you know we've
heard these arguments there's a manual
with a bunch of different arguments so
it's not like there's an argument that
no one's ever seen before so a case for
christ's case for church case for this
case for that
you know mere christianity go through
all the books that is out there right
okay fine
but
you know this is not even a spiritual
argument this is just a question
so is it fair to say that people were
more naive 2000 years ago than today
not even in what person naive in a way
that it was easier to control the
populace 2000 years ago versus today
you think it's easier to control the
populace today or 2000 years ago
probably today really you think that
you think today versus 2 000 years ago
why do you think because i think we're
more connected and everybody seems to
have a platform
on which they can
put out their belief or you know their
thoughts 2 000 years ago we didn't have
all the technology where everybody could
have their own little
podcast or show where they could put
their thoughts out there it was a pretty
limited
way that a message could be put out sure
so doesn't that make it easier to get
more of the populace to believe one
message two thousand years ago than
today
possibly right possibly possibly okay so
where today
you know
you see the the church attendance down
you see you know uh
tithing is down you see all this data
that's coming out right you go to
churches you're like okay they're having
a hard time with their argument and
messaging some churches are growing lds
church is growing there's some you know
uh uh
sanks you know that that are grown but
for the most part you'll hear a lot of
people say church attendance is down you
see that data all over the place it's
not i'm not the one that's talking about
this but
going back to it like i look at my kids
when melva who is mexican our nanny
she's a catholic
and i remember watching her the way she
would make the kids eat food at night
and i would watch her and she would say
tico you better eat this food because
coyotes are coming coyotes are coming
and she would look outside the window
coyotes are outside
and my son would eat the food oh my gosh
coyotes are coming so i'm sitting i'm
like what the hell is coyote okay at
this point the only thing i can link
oyota to is it sounds like coyote so is
it she but there's no way in the world
she's saying the coyotes are coming to
come and eat my
69 i said jen what is what is coyote is
kyoto what i think it is she says yeah
it's coyotes okay i said so this woman's
been telling these kids coyotes are
coming a few thousand times
one day these kids are going to be 38
years old and they're going to be afraid
to go back outside in a backyard because
they're afraid there's coyotes there
because when they were kids somebody
told them coyotes are coming right
so now this somebody might say come on
patrick what a ludicrous argument you're
making here but i think there's a way to
control the populace through fear
and and the way to do that is to
convince them that there is
such thing as the devil
that he can control you and he can harm
you and he can do all these things to
you
and then you see people getting scared
and it's so much easier through
imagination to control them back then
maybe not as much today maybe it's still
effective i don't know now again this is
the argument
i would make years ago
and there was always a different uh
rebuttal to it i'm curious to know what
you say to this when you hear maybe we
have to convince the populace there is
the devil and then let their imagination
convince them that they are possessed
and sometimes our imagination can take
us to some wild places and do some wild
things and some crazy things
and uh things that don't exist what do
you say to that
i would say that you know the church's
stance on the devil isn't meant to
scare people i mean the church proposes
but it doesn't impose
i think to me it's not about having
people live in fear the focus should be
on people living in love which is
basic premise you know of the new
testament god is love
and how do people experience that notion
of god see i would say that you talk
about declining
you know church attendance
the number of people who believe in god
is in decline
for me it's because people don't have a
proper
understanding of who god is
you know if you were to ask people who
is god what is god
what response would you get
creator they would go to
go ahead
but i think for the most part people
would come up with a concept of god
that's based on fear
the hell fire and brimstone
so i do think a lot of people today and
this is only my opinion where people
have a distorted image of god
and to me the ministry of exorcism
really is trying to help people have a
better understanding of who or what god
is so really the focus is not on the
devil and people might be surprised with
that response
but it's really
about helping people understand who god
is and what god wants to do in their
life and god speaks for himself i mean
you look into scripture and he says your
enemy the devil
prowls around like a roaring lion
looking for someone to devour resist him
standing firm in your faith and if you
read the new testament just an average
reading new testament you don't have to
go to seminary anything like this you
will find that jesus himself and the 12
and
the church as we know it
which was the diaspora that occurred
after the stoning of stevens in
the dynamite chapters 8 9 into acts 8 9
and 10 of how the christian church you
know spread to glacier corn and the
ephesus and all these places and later
the rest of the world
they were constantly encountering
you know the spirit the spirit of
darkness they were constantly counting
satan they were very aware of his trick
very aware of his schemes and it was
very very prevalent so when you read
that just objectively again you don't
have to go to seminary you see the
loving god that gave his life for us
jesus christ and sent the holy spirit to
be our helper
and
then you also see the spirits of
darkness and it's and it's very very
clear
so i don't think there's a manipulation
that's really necessary if a reasonably
minded person just reads scripture and
god speaks for himself
is there a question was was that a
comment no it it was it was a comment
supporting kind of you know
how would you manipulate the population
2 thousand years ago or now and i say
god speaks
i get that god speaks for himself in
scripture pretty clear and i and i i'm a
i'm a christian so i get that my my
thing is sometimes there are people like
a bob larson or others that will use
that fear
as a way to control a congregation and
happen many many times
and i think the question for me is who
are they promoting are they promoting
god are they promoting themselves what
do you think they're promoting
i think oftentimes they're promoting
themselves the great line in the new
testament for anybody that's a christian
and takes their faith seriously and
wants to be a minister the focus is
in reference it says i must decrease and
he must increase so the focus is always
on
god and what god wants to do and i think
when the focus comes on the individual
too much is when the person has crossed
that fine line
in that in that regard bob larson i i've
i've seen some videos on him that he's
not a household name to me but these
guys like benny hinn or kenneth copeland
or um
what's his name uh ted haggard
it's something like if when i see these
people
something in me and my stomach just is
like ugh this is this is not
this is not legit
i don't know what it is
call me a skeptic
i see these people coming on stage
and it's just like
yeah just bs i'm not gonna curse in
front of a priest but
i could go deeper than bs
so these types of people these
televangelists does do you think that
this gives the church a bad name
i think i think it does i mean i've had
people reach out to me before and
they're they say i'm possessed how much
will you charge you know the church
doesn't charge anyone
for the ministry of exorcism it's
believed to be a ministry of charity
it's at the core of what the church is
really all about why the church exists
i had a gentleman one time who reached
out to me
from the state of virginia and he was
convinced that he was possessed and i i
talked with him and i was able to
connect him
with a
mental health expert in his area
but he was still convinced even though
he was told
this is not demonic you are suffering
from a mental health issue
so he called me back and said i found a
professional exorcist
who told him that he was possessed by
five demons and he was going to charge
him fifteen hundred dollars each to cast
them out
now that's really sad because here's a
guy that obviously
is broken
on many different levels and now
someone's going to take advantage of him
just for their own financial gain
and then that's the part where they he
gains credibility because there is no
money for this correct so do you
understand what i'm saying when i say
motive there's not a money for this so
okay 99 of them who call you
they don't need you right
mental go see a therapist go do see a
doctor etc etc okay the one percent that
does is the four signs you look for but
you haven't seen it yet right because
the four signs of unbelievable strength
speaking a different language you know
all this you haven't experienced that
what is the one percent that tells you
karen we got to meet with this person
because this sounds like something's
really going on what are some of the
things you notice with the one percent
because the one percent the initial
things that i would tell them when they
first reach out to me is
do the normal aspects of a faith life
you don't have to do anything
extraordinary
but you know are you are you going to
church are you worshiping god whatever
faith tradition you have you know the
church isn't trying to proselytize
anyone through the ministry of exorcism
if somebody is rooted in some faith
tradition the first thing i would tell
them
have you gone and spoken to your pastor
have you spoken to your rabbi have you
spoken to your imam
if so if you have a faith you know
background have you gone and explored
that with whatever faith leader that you
have
because again
i think a lot of people today and this
has been my experience they're looking
for a quick fix
they simply believe they're dealing with
the demonic they believe i have a bag of
tricks
you know i can make their problems go
away
but they don't have any skin in the game
but ultimately people need to realize
that the best defense
is to live out one's faith
it doesn't mean one has to become some
holy roller or whatever it's somebody
who believes that god
has a place
in their life that god has a role to
play
okay so
the time where the person levitated and
you saw that okay
how many pre how many sessions did it
take for this person to go back to being
normal oh nothing ever happened you know
what was the results with that
individual
father carmine would meet with people
you know sometimes people
that were dealing with the demonic it
was one session and they were free
other times it may have taken multiple
sessions
and sometimes people will then ask the
question why is it more than once jesus
commanded the demons to leave they did
so immediately
and at least in my experience it has to
do with the strength of the
demonic possession that's taking place
and somebody has really been forthright
in telling me everything about their
situation sometimes people are
embarrassed
it would be like going to your doctor
and not telling your doctor everything
without that information
the doctor can't give you the right help
that you need so i always say
i'm not there to judge somebody on why
they may have opened up an entry point
to the demonic in their life but i need
to understand it so i can know how to
help them close that doorway but again
it's not just a matter of casting the
demon out god has to be invited in
luke's gospel in chapter 11. it talks
about how once the demon has been cast
out it goes and wanders through the arab
wasteland and then coming back and
finding the house swept clean it goes
and brings seven other demons worse than
itself and they take up residence in the
person
being swept clean meaning it was cast
out but god wasn't invited in
and i do see a lot of people today who
believe they're dealing with the demonic
who want the demonic to go away but they
want nothing to do with god
but what they fail to realize that in an
exorcism
jesus is not a bystander he's the main
actor
so if they're not inviting christ into
their life at that moment if they're a
christian then obviously
things aren't going to play out very
well do you think there's more
demonic activity today or we just are
more
aware of it
i would say and this has been my
experience over the last 17 years it's
not that the devil has upped his game
but that more people today seem to be
willing to play the devil's game
what's the devil's game
to get people to reject god
an inch from christ is victory that's
his game
just non-believers correct specifically
in christ
yeah i think there's a lot of people
you know you look at a lot of satanic
groups
some of them they're very various levels
i think some that are on the superficial
level don't really worship satan but
their goal would be to remove god
from the conversation you see that
played out where maybe some government
groups get together and they have some
type of opening prayer
and then satanic groups will want the
the right to come in and be able to
offer some prayer as well and i would
say it isn't that they want to offer a
prayer they simply want prayer to be
eliminated as a part of that gathering
is jesus the only cure for someone who's
possessed
i would say ultimately it would be with
god so again you look at other faith
traditions and
yeah again i would go back to what i
said earlier the catholic church doesn't
have a monopoly because ultimately is
what god is doing but i've seen like a
million videos of someone who's
possessed by the devil demons what have
you and it's always a cross that they
put on their forehead i never see you
know star of david or a crescent moon or
you know a buddhist figure a hindu
figure
uh so it seems to be i know you said
they don't have a monopoly but you know
it's probably more prevalent yeah at
least from a christian perspective you
know why is the crucifix used
you know so
jesus at the beginning of his public
ministry
you know he's baptized and then he's
driven out into the desert by the spirit
where he's tempted by
the devil
the devil's not successful then we're
told the devil leaves him for a time
when does the devil return it's in the
garden of gethsemane when the devil
enters into judas who then betrays
christ which leads to the crucifixion
as jesus is being crucified the devil
believes that he is one but the moment
of his perceived victory actually
becomes
the moment of his defeat which is why a
crucifix is used so it's not
you know the crucifix that has the power
it's what it's pointing towards our
redemption in christ it's the same way
with like holy water i people tell me
all the time well you know i went got
the exorcism kit you know it i got the
water i got the oil
the water points to our baptism into
christ by which we have become a new
creation if somebody's just using water
for the sake of water
that's not going to do them any good it
always has to point to something
greater got it when i was young i used
to believe in uh vampires
and then you know the you know all those
movies that kind of that kind of stuff
uh and how do you defeat a vampire holy
water sunlight
uh garlic or you behead the the vampire
or a crucifix or a wooden stake okay
that too
so and then i realized yeah wait wait
it's gotta be okay it was probably
probably not
vampires probably don't exist
i don't wanna you know let the cat out
the bag
but they're probably not really here
it's sort of you know
folklore what have you
but it seems that's
there's a is there a metaphor there with
a lot of people like also the salem
witch trials right people thought that
these women were possessed by black
magic and they were burned at the stake
so there's it's
there's sort of
hysteria hysteria can take over there's
no doubt well pat asked you a question
2000 years ago was it easier to convince
people versus today i wholeheartedly
believe that it was much easier back in
the day
right today you can have a million
different opinions you've kind of
figured out maybe you can kind of live
in an echo chamber or a siphon depending
on who you're listening to but back in
the day there was
one book called the bible that everyone
kind of had to listen to depending on
where you were in the world or the quran
or the old testament what have you and
people kind of fell into place
so
i don't know i just again skeptical and
i'm looking for
for answers here and then
it just seems this is very common in the
catholic faith i'm jewish i've never
seen anyone who's jewish possessed by
the devil so you talk about this all the
time that words of power words have
power if you keep telling yourself
you're a loser you're nothing you'll
never amount to nothing guess what
happens you're probably never going to
amount to nothing so if you keep seeing
things like the devil possessed the
devil blah blah you kind of fall into
that trap that's
kind of where i'm at with this yeah tell
me i'm crazy tell me i'm wrong tell me
i'm an idiot
i had a friend his name is saul okay
and he lived in sylmar
and saul was a great fighter him and his
brother were fighters boxers that were
insane strand like just they would knock
people out on a heart and they know how
to fight like i'm talking mma fighting
but i would go to his place and he would
say you won't even believe i said do you
believe in the devil i said what does
the devil look like and he told me so
tell me exactly what he said i've met
him before yeah i said you met the devil
before he says i have
so i said so tell me what was it like he
says uh
one day the devil was pulling me from my
leg out of the house and my brother was
pulling me back in the house and the
devil was trying to pull me and we're
going back and forth i was able to pull
him in and the devil got away
so i heard his story and i'm like you
really believe this he says yes
i'm like how do you believe this is what
how do you not believe this so we're
going back having this friendly debate
but to me
you know if if i were to say some
denominations are way more creative on
how they sell the devil to their
congregation
and the credibility of it and it really
really gets some folks to
go in because okay so imagine if you're
we're about to play some tapes here of
annalise michelle okay
if you're in your house by yourself and
you're watching this podcast at 11
o'clock you live in a one bedroom
apartment and you hear some noise from
outside or a light
and you're watching this
what do you think your imagination is
going to go if you're a regular human
being you're going to say
you're like yeah okay it's not a big
deal let me tell you if you're a regular
human being but one time have i told you
a story what happened when the next door
neighbors at a hotel were making it out
of course and you put the but i haven't
talked about it on the podcast or i
would say i don't know you have i don't
know we can tell the story i'm not going
to say it but the point is very very
famous people's imagination really goes
to a different place well especially
when it's dark outside especially you
can play those videos okay so when it's
light outside yeah i'm good dark
midnight you're going to probably get a
little scary you know how you said
there's some
is there is it caught on tape those five
videos i watched last night of exorcisms
that was caught on tape one of them was
at a catholic church where they were
recording it through the doorknob i
don't know if you've seen this one or
not okay then there was a couple other
ones i saw but the last one was a case
of a guy
that the camera's on his face
his eyes roll back and this is an older
clip and a guy's skin splits okay
now i'm not i'm not kidding with you
this is caught on tape and i'll send it
to you right now if i find it to go
i'll find it i'll send it to you while
we're looking at this one here you know
how what can you tell us about this case
that we're not aware of what what what
do we know
outside of what the public knows that
this inspired to be the movie the
exorcism emily rose what can you tell
the audience about this case of annalise
michelle
well are people familiar with the case
so it's uh assume they're not assume
none of us are
so they the premise is so this is a lady
in germany
who was uh determined to be possessed
she was working with a priest
and then she never did receive complete
deliverance
from the demonic oppression
and then she eventually died
at 23 years old she died
and first she started experiencing this
at 16 years old
and she would go to six different voices
she would make right it's nero
kane judas hitler fleischmann a missing
one
lucifer and each voice sounds different
and then eventually i mean you look at
her right now i want you to watch this i
want to get your reaction on this this
is right here and at least michelle
who if you listen to her voice sounds
like a regular voice speaking in german
if you want to play so the audience can
hear it
very normal
okay very normal fast forward to now
what she uh yeah go right there so this
is this is hitler
[Music]
i hope you're not watching this late at
night if you are
here's kane
[Applause]
very disturbing okay go to the next one
this is nero
this is fleischmann
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay for the next one
[Music]
is
okay pause it at this point i said it's
going to be disturbing i got to leave
no but but you but you know what though
here's the part so
first of all i feel bad for this girl
she passed away 23 years old okay you're
talking about somebody the mother that's
the mother standing right next to her i
mean they made a movie about this this
turned into a story that people watched
and
you know uh uh
you know you
even even if you try like yesterday
vinnie who's outside who doesn't like
vinnie got a shout out on this but uh
vinnie i said try making the sound
naturally
like if you really try to yourself make
this sound naturally go go try to do it
how does somebody do it naturally right
okay you may say i know certain people
that could do it
but this is a little strange adam you
can make a crazy advice like there's
people who they can do
it's not that hard to do part the part
he says the part he says
where it's those four signs yeah
unbelievable
out of nowhere power
that comes in okay like you know
somebody on pcp i don't know if you've
seen somebody on pcp yeah they can lift
the car up they can lift they said so
that's that part the other part is
language spoken that you don't speak
okay yeah and then third one is same
information and things that you
shouldn't know those those
those two maybe not the first one but
those two
it's a little so when you see that have
you ever personally witnessed somebody
like that oh yeah i've seen all those
things all the time you're being serious
you've seen that day in the life
well and because of the number of people
that contact me
that it would be
yeah an ordinary part i mean i have no
other exorcists
who say they've never dealt with a case
of possession in the years that they've
been an exorcist
but some of them some of us are publicly
known that some choose to remain
anonymous and those who are publicly
known we do receive a higher volume of
people who reach out to us
what's the key to success of the ones
that are successful and someone has
deliverance and can go live a
a life where they've you know replaced
it with you know this belief in christ
and now they're able to live free
what's the key to the success when
you've gone through your
you know your filters that you've
described
what's that key
is there a key is there something common
to the people that
now live free
i think there is first of all i would
say that
you know often oftentimes people that
suffer are suffering alone they're in
isolation
so bringing them back into a sense of
community helping people reconnect with
family and friends
another probably the biggest one is
helping people
connect with god in their life because
again it's not just a matter of casting
the evil out i've said that before i
can't say it enough
it's about helping people develop
an authentic relationship with god
you know it makes me think of the stair
the story of the garrison demoniac in
chapter five of mark's gospel that you
know the man who's possessed by legion
he's living in the tombs
you know shackles won't even hold him
there's the superhuman strength he's
possessed by legion
jesus casts the demons out
they go into the swine the demons show
their true character they destroy the
swine they race over the hillside they
drown in the lake most people when
they're reading that biblical account
will stop reading at that point but i
would suggest the most important thing
happens next
the man who's now free wants to follow
jesus and jesus says no now how often in
the bible does jesus tell somebody not
to follow him
what does jesus say to him no go home to
your family so jesus takes someone who
was living amongst the dead in the tombs
and places them back amongst the living
with his family
so again
creating healthy
relationships
is one of the ways that evil can be
defeated
oh and in that story you know christ
also invented devil tam
so annelise michelle had 67 exorcisms
67 and she my understanding was she was
a devout
catholic before she became possessed if
you will
went to church
every sunday prayed all the time i
believe her knees broke or
suffered serious injury because she was
praying so often
she had epilepsy she had a seizure when
she was 16
and went into psychosis so my question
to you would be now there's a very key
point in there where i think i believe
i've heard you say that people will
start to speak latin
like classic latin that nobody today
speaks
she doesn't at least not on camera
perhaps it was she did it just wasn't
recorded
how much of this could actually just be
attributed to her psychosis or
schizophrenia or epilepsy or what have
you like
my problem is i i do believe but i'm a
skeptic but like people equate this to
aliens and you can almost make the case
that aliens have more traction than
demonic possession especially today so
like what
obviously it's just a belief but like
why is this real why is this just not
epilepsy or schizophrenia
well they've got a couple comments i was
going to make you know
[Music]
the church has clear teaching on the
reality that evil is personified but a
lot of the things that we witness there
isn't any clear teaching on that
so like is she possessed by nero is she
possessed by judas
that would raise the question
can
the souls of the damned possess people
and so was that really
judas was that really nero or where
hitler or whatever or were they demons
who were mimicking those personalities
as a way to feed into the audience if
you will because the gun the
the goal of any demon would be to sow
confusing confusion
to really just make things really hard
to understand and comprehend and
watching this
that's exactly what would happen
yeah um
i want to go back to the what's the
motivation here i'm zero percent
questioning your motivation however
i am questioning the motivation of the
catholic church
not sure if you've heard the news
catholic church hasn't exactly have a
great reputation these days the movie uh
spotlight all that stuff i'm not talking
about the kids and we won't go there but
i mean if we do whatever but not exactly
the best reputation these days but i'm
talking you're talking about motivation
and incentives maybe
uh you know if the church
kind of promotes demons if there's no
demons maybe there's no devil
and if there's no devil maybe there's no
god so maybe
going down that path
it behooves the church to sort of
incentivize that there are in fact
demons and to go down the path of well
the demons the god you know the devil
and all that so i guess my question is
from uh you asked about motivation what
incentivizes i'm not saying that it's
you but there is seems to be an
incentive
for the church to
promote
these demons or these exorcisms because
you know how would how else would you go
towards the path of god you know the
good and bad type of thing if there's no
devil
i would say you know it isn't that the
church is promoting exorcism
the church is promoting
god i mean i don't go out and randomly
say to people on the street hey i think
you're possessed you need an exorcism so
it isn't that i'm going out and telling
people they need an exorcism it's people
that are coming to the church and then
out of a ministry of charity
the church will
look into what they believe to be the
case and then to weigh in on that
now ultimately
because the majority of people as i
mentioned have already self-diagnosed
if i tell somebody that i don't believe
that they're possessed
guess what they're going to find
somebody out there who's going to agree
with them people will continue to shop
around
until they get what they want
you want you said that you just wanted
to become a priest right that was your
motivation
right that's at the core of of
christianity
is you know what did jesus do in his
life you read biblical accounts and i
would suggest that jesus came to destroy
the devil
but that's the work with the church
today my question is pat said why would
you want to become an ex or an exorcist
he said we were like well i didn't
really want to become an extras i want
to become a priest and then you got a
phone call one day i assumed by the
church and they're like
you're up buddy we're going to need an
exorcist in indiana and you're the guy
and i assume you're not going to say no
to that
no because as a priest when you're
ordained you promise obedience to your
bishop exactly that's my point so
they're going to say hey time for you to
become the exorcist you say all right i
promise obedience so that's my new job
so it's part of it you're not going to
say no
so like that's your job now so now it's
your job as an exorcist to go
do exorcism so back to my initial point
it's sort of like the churches
but even when you're pushing this upon
but even
but having that role
it's really up to me to determine
how to live that out
it's not that the bishop's calling me
every day and saying hey i expected you
to do 10 exorcisms today it really is
even when i got the appointment it's
really up to me to determine how to
live out that role i mean i could choose
to remain anonymous the bishop who
appointed me
he even encouraged me to help educate
people what the church believes and
teaches to to use it as a uh an
educative role if you will
but again there are some exorcists you
can just kind of stay off in the shadows
and
nobody will even know who you are or
what you do and but the church is aware
you're out there doing podcasts and
putting putting this out there sure but
again and but it's a way to help educate
people and you know people can agree
with me they can disagree with me they
can agree with the church or disagree
but my goal is simply to present
take advantage of opportunities present
what the church believes what people do
with that is up to them i'm not offended
or i don't get
upset or angry it's just a matter of
saying this is what the church believes
i throw it out there what people do with
it ultimately is up to them so so tom i
want your involvement at this one when i
when i say this help me out if i'm
missing something here because i know
you you have a lot of expertise in this
as well so here's here's how i view some
of this and father i want to get your
commentary on this too
is
you know when you meet a kid like donald
trump jr
he's an incredible troll
very good at what he does well he
learned from his father his father is
one of the best trolls we've had the
last hundred years he knows how to get
under people's skins and he's natural at
it right so there's a part of that
teaching that gets passed down to
you know him joseph kennedy the way he
was
you know a lot of his habits also got
passed down to john f kennedy okay very
similar both were very good with women
and words and all this stuff so genetics
apart gets passed down okay
uh you know steve kerr played under
michael jordan it was played under phil
jackson coached under greg popovich
and he played for san antonio so not
only coached and so a lot of his
teaching goes to you know golden state
warriors and you see okay actors who
were coached under same you know acting
coach and aaron spicer or whatever style
you want to put in there or you got
directors who worked under somebody else
or
you got generals who have a certain way
of attacking lineage pedigree
so to me is each religion go to each
religion like bill maher's biggest
criticism of muslim is what you can't
tell me
that christians have this many
extremists like muslims do we can't just
set this aside we have to talk about
this so he has been afflicted and it
becomes this massive uproar of debate
sam harris they're all debating so you
say you can't say i don't get a lot of
extremists that come out of catholicism
when it comes down to
you know going and maybe bombing a
building you don't hear that coming up
from the criticism is different from
catholicism than it is from that okay
muslim is that christianity
has its own set of criticism jews you'll
hear a lot of times oh look at jews are
very good with their money i wonder why
what are they teaching maybe they spend
a little bit more time teaching finances
money discipline you know certain things
that they do and okay so mormons they
have a lot of kids why do they have a
lot of kids mormons if you're a mormon
the one thing that you get with them
forget about the gordon b hinckley
forget about the cr you know the
criticism of god makers or whatever you
want i'm not talking about the criticism
but you'll be able to say hey if there's
one thing about the mormon church they
all do business together they'll back
each other up they're all together they
go so okay let's go to the the more and
more you go here you know
rituals i don't think any religion has
more rituals well maybe some do but
catholicism there's a lot of rituals
it's filled with rituals and rituals
builds a culture ritual unites your
ritual is a we trust rituals we feel
safe when you go into a church and you
know there's a certain element to it
where you feel
safe about it but
to have a 90 of exorcisms being done by
catholic church
you know a part of it gets me to think
about the following here's what it gets
me to think about
kids will generally want to impress
their parents
and they will either impress their
parents or or they'll go against their
parents because of resentment father
left mother left mom did something so
i'm either gonna be like my dad or i'm
gonna be anything but like my dad but
typically that part is natural right
so for me if a congregation you can't
see talking about the devil the devil
the devil the devil let's just say if
you do i'm not saying you do or not but
if you do
then some people want to act it out and
some people want to believe it and then
some people want to internalize it and
some people start their imagination
takes over it's like let me tell you
what i'm going through and i'm possessed
and i'm going through this maybe because
they've witnessed it they're seeing it
they're constantly being talked about so
the imagination takes over in the form
of wanting to get attention now i don't
look at analysts michelle and say why
would anybody want to get this kind of
attention hurt themselves the way they
do
but
what do you say to someone who's
listening and saying why are a lot of
these things
happening specifically in the catholic
church and not necessarily some other
churches
well i would go back to what i said
earlier that uh
half the people that i talk to are not
catholic
so it isn't that it's just happening in
the catholic church i think it's
happening
in the broad base of society
but the catholic church seems to be
where the majority of people go
when they believe they're up against the
demonic
but i wouldn't say that
everybody who's dealing with the demonic
is catholic because even as a priest
i've been a priest now for 31 years
i mean i don't preach on the devil all
the time
my focus would be preaching on god
and trying to focus on the importance of
goodness and love those are the things
tom you've been part of the church for a
long time as well right
how many times did you
see people coming in to a
non-denominational church about needing
a parent needing an exorcism or they're
going through
you know
uh
they're possessed or they're going
through it how many of those stories
have you heard
i've heard quite a few but at the front
of the pulpit unfortunately
to answer your question directly
in
most american
christian churches i think they've done
a very
poor job
of not focusing on it but even touching
on it because many of them don't want to
be seen as
sensationalist or weird of course the
catholic church has done i think a very
good job of basically saying hey
we're training our priests in this we
have people that are called we're
calling people out who they're through
their
to their traditions or standards the
bishop calling you out
i don't mean calling you out like in the
modern day we say it but calling you
into a particular ministry of service
um in the christian church what happens
is people usually come
to the church privately
and it's not really spoken from the from
the pulpit and those are the two points
that i would make is unfortunately a
christian church does not speak from the
pulpit
about
personal oppression and deliverance
very much at all
or as a catholic church does but there i
know of
and we could talk to pastor that we both
know people do come to the church office
my son myself then and they come
privately because the american
christians also don't want to be
weird or stigmatized but there's a good
amount of it that comes to it privately
i will say too that prior to
1972
every priest when he was ordained one of
the minor orders he received was
the order of exorcist
so i i i went to the seminary in chicago
up in mundoline illinois and i still
remember on the stairs of the sanctuary
leading up to the altar they would have
the orders of
priesthood leading up to priesthood and
one of them was exorcist but after 1972
the church removed that minor order
because they really wanted to give the
ministry of exorcism to people who are
well trained not just any priest who
would then believe that anybody's coming
to him so i would say that the church
has actually kind of tried to
clamp down
by only having certain priests
specialize in the area of exorcism
whereas prior to 1972
it was a place for every priest to
receive the minor order of exorcist
you're saying that then it became
sensationalized and so the church wanted
to make sure that there was a
effectiveness and purity to it correct i
saw an argument i saw an argument made
about this to say the following so uh
when were when did mris become a thing
uh can you can you when was the first
mri ever conducted tyler can you pull
that up
when was the first mri conducted okay
uh 1977 is the first time we did an mri
okay so that's not a long time ago it's
july 3rd 1977. so
up until 1977 we don't fully know
what the brain is doing right up until
1977. so
a lot of it if somebody's exercise doing
you know
exorcisms it's just maybe a guessing
game because we don't know
1977 we come out with a magnetic you
know resonance imaging so i just did an
mri last week i just went through an mri
two weeks ago for my hand broken two
ligaments
fractured my six-year-old daughter broke
my thumb
something she's gonna brag about for the
rest of her life i've broken a couple
bones in my life one of them was broken
by a six-year-old she's so proud of it
she laughs every time i say it so you go
get an mri done in the brain
and then you see the two sides of it
right you got the structural mri
you got the
definitional mri okay one of them is
more the structure the other one's the
activity
when they did the mri when they looked
at some folks that had you know they
they thought they were being possessed
uh on one end you have the two sides of
the brain okay the
hippocampus and the amygdal mcdonald
amygdala right
one of the sides it was a reduction of
19.2 percent and the other one was a
31.6 reduction in the region of the
brain that gets extremely creative and
emotional right
and then
the argument that this doctor was making
the fact that now that we have the mri
we are realizing
that the brain can really do a number on
you when it goes on its own specifically
the side that's the amygdala side that's
more the creative the activity you can
kind of see what's going on with it so
the this is what i mean by education
technology advancement a lot of this is
taking the credibility out to say all
these years we thought there was really
people being possessed but we're at a
point right now that when somebody's
going through that rather than going and
seeing an exorcist maybe they got to go
get an mri done of their brain
to see what the activity they're
noticing then the doctor can say yeah
this person's going through this here's
what their challenge they're having what
are your thoughts when you hear a doctor
making an argument to say
the mri now validates that you know
there's no such thing as being possessed
and needing a an exorcist what would you
say to that
i go back again from a faith perspective
in the new testament when jesus sent his
disciples out
he gave them authority over unclean
spirits but he also gave them power to
cure those who were sick so jesus
himself made a distinction between
ailments that were due to demonic causes
and ones that were just purely physical
in nature
and i think that that continues today so
yeah there are some that are certainly
due to uh physical maladies but i still
believe that there are some that are due
to demonic causes but again that would
be going and doing
that investigation trying to determine
how that came about so when you said
before they come to see you they got to
go see the doctor they got to have this
they got to have that is a part of it
nmri is a part of it to go see
the brain activity that's taking place
or no whatever the
expert would recommend
yeah like and by the way when you guys
go through the exorcism do you do you
ever communicate directly with a doctor
of the patient or the individual or have
you ever had a
direct communication with a doctor or no
i i will say that always
but not all these other professionals
would be willing to accept that maybe
they're spiritual causes
so they may not be willing to speak with
me or they may not be willing to speak
with you right got it
yeah i i would be i would be
curious to hear a debate between a
person who does exorcists like yourself
and a person who has experience doing
this
with samples and examples they have to
bring mris and say here's a person that
we thought was possessed but this is the
challenge that they were having
and here's how we were able to help this
person out through xyz
um
look i'm i'm in a place where
it's very very close relatives that have
witnessed going through stuff like this
and and it was as strange as it could be
where you sit there and you watch this
and you say okay now i've seen the trend
of how to get attention for this
and you know but you know how sometimes
like
when somebody is not getting love from
somebody what's their way of getting
love from the other person you know some
some dark places that people will go to
to get love from somebody and get
attention you know i want to kill myself
okay
yep i don't know if you've ever gotten a
call from somebody saying i'm committing
suicide i'm going to kill myself you
ever gone through that has that i've
dealt with okay so you i know you've
dealt i'm not asking specifics but we've
all everybody in their families has some
strange stories right with different
people
and you know it's almost if the if the
if the parents
or the
individuals in that person's life gives
it too much attention they want to do it
more because it hurts you
it's like oh my gosh
please don't commit suicide like they
almost it's it's a look we're here for
you we love you there's more you know
there's more things that we need to do
but i've seen the you know the other
side where sometimes people also use
some of these things to get attention
because it's a form of love maybe they
didn't have love growing up there's a
lot of
a lot of strange ways people are raised
a lot of messed up families in the world
we're very very good at hiding our
you know dirt and our families from
people but we got some real
messed up lives that people have been
raised in
and sometimes you know we
say in even with that i'm going to go do
something big with my life and i'm going
to win and sometimes we use that as a
way of this is why i'm not winning
but
i'm not convinced either side is 100
right i will say i was i was as you were
talking i was thinking about a
a man who was referred to me he had
already been diagnosed as being
schizophrenic
so he already had a psychiatrist he was
working with he had a case worker
but then the priest in his parish asked
if i would meet with him and i did and
you know i made i went through my intake
questionnaire and all these things and
determined it was not demonic this truly
was something of a mental health issue
now i didn't want to just tell him that
and send him on his way
his psychiatrist and caseworker were
willing to meet with me
so me the gentleman and then these other
two folks we met
and so i said to him
you know we'll call him jojo you're not
possessed
and the psychiatrist says to him joe
father says you're not possessed what is
your response
and i was really intrigued by his
response because what he said was this
he said i'm disappointed
he said
to the psychiatrist you can tell me that
i'm schizophrenic but you can't tell me
why
he goes if it's the devil i have my why
so i think there's a lot of people when
they're trying to sort out
what they're dealing with they may turn
to the demonic but again i go back to
my role as an exorcist i need to have
moral certitude
believing beyond a doubt that this truly
is something
demonic in nature and as a priest i
would never use the right of exorcism
as a diagnostic tool
or if i thought somebody really wasn't
possessed i wouldn't just pray with them
just to kind of feed into whatever they
believe because ultimately i believe
that would cause greater harm so i have
to tell people what i believe
to be the situation
and then what they do that what they do
with it is up to them and again it goes
back to
the fact that in today's world you can
find anybody to agree with what you
believe and if i tell somebody that's
schizophrenic they've been diagnosed
that they're not possessed they're going
to go out and find somebody else who's
going to validate that they are
possessed and take advantage of them let
me let me ask you a strange question
have we ever had anybody that's been
famous
slightly famous
that was ever possessed that needed an
exorcist exorcism done on them
i can't think of anyone that's wow why
let me explain what i mean by like a
basketball player
baseball player
an actor a politician a military leader
anybody that was
somebody of influence
why haven't they ever why if the devil
is
doing what he's doing why isn't he going
and possessing those guys from
preventing them
from maybe there's a you know
maybe there's somebody that's can make a
why is he going after people that we
don't know regular folk can i follow up
on that real quick i actually want to
hear that answer yeah and then you can
follow
what you hear from these famous people
is they've sold their soul to the devil
yeah that's how they got famous and so
to your point yeah i'd like to hear his
response
yeah because again i think it would be
that
somebody would have to come public first
of all they would have to want to
share their story there could be the
stigma that people will think that
they're
not in their right mind and then maybe
they're going to lose their
whatever position the power prestige
that they have so they may not be
willing to step forward
goes back to the question again so why
does the average joe get possessed but
somebody that's more prominent doesn't
and the key would be whether or not
somebody is truly seeking help
that's the key thing whether or not
somebody's famous whether or not they're
not famous
again i don't go out and search for
people that i believe to be but if the
spirit gets a hold of you do you have
any control
so if you even if you're famous and
powerful if the spirit gets ahold of you
you mean to tell me you're more powerful
than the spirit
no you know what i'm saying it depends
on the degree that one's dealing with
the demonic because something of the
person always remains free that's why
even somebody that's possessed could ask
for help
it's not total there is something that's
called a perfect possession
where somebody takes their free will and
they unite their free will completely
with the demonic
so there never would be any
manifestations then the fact that there
are manifestations would indicate that
there's still an internal battle there's
still a struggle that's taking place
but it could be that somebody is
possessed but because they've resigned
their free will to the will of the devil
there is no manifestation there's no
battle to take place
yeah but if if the devil is so strong
why is he why does he have a hard time
getting a hold of
other people that are influencers
why why why and by the way to say that
maybe we don't know about it when you're
famous we know all your business you
know the people that get
criticism is fame like you know some
people want to go i'd love to go out
there and become successful like that
guy or this guy or that guy and i'd love
to have you know be a basketball player
and get all the fame i'd love to be a
hollywood star but the moment you go
there all your business is everyone's
business hey this person's brother did
this
patrick mahomes brother went through
this
tom brady's going through this in his
you know issue that's why he took a
break that person is going through this
i mean
because even when you're you can't talk
by yourself somebody's gonna leak
something you know i told a friend of
mine one time i said i said when i when
you and i talk about my personal life do
you tell your wife
you said it's my wife i'm married to her
so you can't tell you tell my business
to your wife why because even if you
tell your wife what if you and your wife
get a divorce one day what's her loyalty
to my
secrets of my life that i shared with
you and the struggles that i have
there's no loyalty so that has to stay
between you and i he said that totally
makes sense and it finally made sense
i'm like okay great so even if you're
famous sometimes your biggest fear is
who do i confide in but eventually
you're gonna confide in somebody and
that person's gonna leak you this is why
they'll say such and such has agreed to
three year contract extension
okay this person has just gone
so i don't know why people who are more
because if let's just say you have to
think about the devil right if you are
the devil
you go take somebody
that's got influence over what
one person or nobody why would you do
that
then you're a small thinker
so if if we are saying the devil is as
power which by the way i do believe
i do believe if you wrestle with them
you better have somebody backing you up
i do believe that
but my interpretation is a different
interpretation
my interpretation is an exorcism
interpretation
my interpretation is for him to convince
you
you know for for people sometimes to
believe that they don't need help they
don't need faith they don't need a
higher power to back them up i believe
for what i want to do in my life i need
faith i need i need backing for somebody
to back me up i want favor
i want favor at the highest level
because i do think there's going to be
challenges i do think there's going to
be people that are going to get in the
way and i do believe sometimes maybe if
there is a devil he uses people to get
in the way of you doing something big
but it's not the devil of
you know things like this because if the
devil is really doing this
he should target players and influencers
to get them to drop because if they drop
then
he wins at a higher level yeah and it
could be that people are dealing with
the demonic they're just not aware of it
because ultimately the devil doesn't
want to be
in the spotlight he prefers to work in
the shadows if you will
you're a bully if you're going after
helpless people like what outcome do you
have of going after annelise michelle
like what did you do with that
like let's play the game and go in the
devil's conference room with 12 other
masters and you know advisors sitting
there okay let's go after annelise
michelle what's your outcome what a what
a week
you know how much weakness you're
showing if you're going after a helpless
16 year old kid what do you think you
did you didn't do anything special but
then see then that that's a great point
then the devil is showing his true
character
so the devil believes he's doing
something that's advancing his agenda
his kingdom but ultimately all that ends
up doing is advancing the kingdom of god
then maybe we shouldn't be afraid of the
guy which never no one should ever be
afraid of the devil because because
because the point then becomes
he's not as strong as you think he is
it's through your imagination that if
you let your imagination let loose
that's where he destroys you
because he makes you believe there's a
thousand people around the corner that
god is back that will fight you he's by
himself
okay if that's the argument because
i think sometimes the imagination gets
people to
and that and the demonic plays on a
person's memory and imagination right
that was trying to get into your head
and i think in the role of an exorcism
the goal is to get the devil out of your
head and to get god into your head
because yeah the devil there's nothing
to fear
you know a lot of people will watch the
videos of annelise and michelle and you
know they're going to be terrified by
all of that but again they shouldn't be
maybe this is a simple question but so
you you said earlier you came on the
podcast and you speak to people to
educate and to show people and to help
people learn so i guess the simple
question for me is is why not just film
one i understand that you do it for the
privacy of
the person being exercised but why not
blur out their face or why not like does
that destroy the faith element of it
i don't know if it would destroy the
faith element i think skeptics would
still be there you know if there's a
video or so if someone's going to say
well you can tell it was altered here
you're going to get a thousand people
analyzing it from every angle but i
don't even think that if there was one
recorded
that people are going to say well beyond
a doubt i believe now because people are
going to say that
again in today's world anything can be
manipulated and i certainly don't think
it would be you know everybody would now
be a believer but i think it would do
something to help your cause i certainly
think it would it put some weight behind
your cause because i think there was an
exorcism done on
it wasn't a catholic exorcism but it was
done in st louis several years ago there
was a
an archbishop of some church
who did one and it was being televised
on television so it was on television it
was there
but has that really changed the debate
even though one was
supposedly
videotaped then even father gabriel
amorth the former chief exorcist in rome
there's some question on whether or not
he permitted an exorcism that he
performed before he passed away in 2016
to be recorded and there's a recording
out there of it it seems like it was
done on a cell phone
the quality is not very good
but there are some people that say that
even he had permitted one to be recorded
but there have been exorcisms that have
been recorded like there's been there's
a famous one that i sent you to
tyler
on abc uh news
where they recorded the exorcist
it has millions of views this is like 10
years ago uh this lady called becky you
ever seen this this video
okay yeah this is it right here i don't
know if you want to fast forward and you
see this lady
yeah there she is and
she's
yeah footage
actually happens in an exorcism
i would do things
her name she was possessed by demons she
firmly believes yeah so she firmly
believes now it turns out
she was severely abused as a child that
she had major drug issues she's had a
rough life she was a prostitute
and she was a member of a cult how
convenient
so you add all that up
and next thing you know she's possessed
by demons so it's this is i guess to
the point that we're kind of making is
like
99 of people that think they're
possessed by demons turns out it's not
the case that they have major major
major issues going on with their body
something like this doesn't exactly help
the cause to believe that there are
demons it just sort of proves the point
that no there's just some messed up
people out there
and i don't know what they're dealing
with do the presence of all those things
negate that perhaps it was a spiritual
issue
or yes
that's what i'm saying and
it negates it for you
well
i mean
tough life abused drugs i agree
prostitute and a member of a cult i
agree yeah that's not exactly the great
resume that you're going to believe that
person i would look in there that
and say
okay maybe this was sensationalized
right maybe maybe she wasn't
but on the other hand you say could it
be that the drugs the abuse and the
other things
and then the cult is what gave
the ground or the foothold
to demonic activity i don't know the
answer to it and by the way it sure
sounds fishy it does so i'm with you on
that on perception but it's also
those are avenues that could open up a
place where this person could have
legitimately had have you seen things
like this
i've seen things like that
but again early life and some traumas
and other things that led to
ultimately a stronghold
yeah i'm i'm thinking of a uh
a person that i was interviewing who
believed that she was possessed and she
had shared with me that growing up in
mexico at the age of seven her father
began to rape her
so her father raped her from the time
she was seven until she was 12.
and then when she turned 12 her father
she said turned his attention to her
younger sister oh boy so she said she
was
broken blame god for allowing this to
happen in her tradition she turned to
coronderos and brujas
you know witch doctors and witches who
said they could help put the pieces of
her life back together
but that
example of abuse led her down the
pathway
into the world of the occult so she's
telling me this story and she's with a
friend of hers there's me and there's
another priest
and then she's looked at me and she's
crying uncontrollably and she looks at
me and says
will you help me and i say to her
jesus is the one who can help you
and when i said that her eyeballs turned
green her pupils became slanted like a
serpent and this voice comes out of her
mouth and says who's he he has no power
over us
so was she possessed by a demon you
believe
so then again i had her go through steps
to see a psychiatrist and whatnot
and then i did make the decision to pray
with her
and when i made the decision to pray
with her
so we are in a chapel we're praying
and as soon as i begin praying
there's the the demon manifests again
there's the green eyeballs and the demon
looks at me and says you can't get rid
of us we've been here for too long and
you're just not strong enough
yeah but you're talking about a person
who was raped by her father
okay i mean if you want to talk about a
messed up person how messed up can you
get than that and not only that then
he's about to take on the younger sister
after you're 12. so i don't know i'm i'm
not a doctor or anything like that but
like if you want a prescription for
someone who's gonna have a messed up
life boom there you go
so but how do you just how do you
describe the what eyewitness then the
the witnesses are different these are
two different i hear you but it's not
like she was just a normal girl and had
a nice life and just you know every
happy-go-lucky girl and then all of a
sudden the devil pops up because i'm
talking about some of the most
disgusting acts a human can do to
another human is what happened to her
and i hear these stories all the time
that's why i don't just run into the
room
you know with my right of exorcism book
and say here i'm to save the day no
to me there's no such thing as an
emergency exorcism when those things are
done
is when problems really unfold
arriving at doing an exorcism should be
at the end not at the beginning
so like this what we just witnessed
did somebody just walk in and say hey i
i need this exorcism i have people that
tell me all the time i need to come and
have an exorcism today but to me i would
begin by understanding where the person
has been knowing their history were they
traumatized had they been working with
the council or i even tell people it
isn't just a one angle approach
perhaps you do need to have some
deep in spirituality but that doesn't
mean you need an exorcism maybe you need
to reconnect with the church
maybe you need to find god in your life
but then you also need to be seeing the
counselor have you talked to your doctor
it should be a multi-faceted approach
it's not just
one approach
and pat
what's your
skepticism level at this point has it
decreased has it increased is it exactly
the same where are you at right now i
think i think father lampert is a good
man who's doing good service and and
good for his church and society and
and i i don't see any
thing uh where uh
where i see you know here's a give us
this much money we'll do this for you
that's the stuff that's the bob larson
stuff that goes to and he does it live
and he walks around with his cross and
he says oh
no i feel the spirit get out and he does
like it's just that stuff to me is a and
benny hinn benny hinn and you know all
these other things no
but my problem is the people that
believe these people
like you go to the benny hinn's church
and there's thousands upon thousands of
people
like
but but there it is it is a form of a
safety net
to believe and and say this is why my
life is this
this is why it's a it's it's it's a very
comfortable place to
lean towards that but in regards to what
you're saying with uh
you know
the story of the uh the girl 12 year old
possessed daughter dad
and then the eyes turn green
i mean if you're saying you witnessed
that you understand he says
you said you said jesus says who is he
and she says that who is he and when was
this one this when you witnessed this
one this is a recent one
within the last couple years this is
within the last couple years yes
wow
yeah i mean
who else was in the room outside of you
with that one
there was another priest and then
a friend of the lady so there are four
of us has the friend of the lady ever
spoken about it or no
she has with the uh the priest of the
church
anytime i work with somebody then
ultimately
i would put them under the care
of their if they're catholic their
priest and their church yeah somebody's
not catholic the first thing i would
want to do is actually have a
conversation with their religious leader
you know who's the pastor of your church
or
and then would this have a conversation
because again i'm not there to promote
any agenda that i have obviously if
somebody's reaching out to me there's a
brokenness there now is it spiritual is
it mental is it physical i don't know at
that point but i want all of us to try
to work together just to figure out yeah
what is going on just to show some level
of
compassion or charity towards this
person who obviously is hurting i
respect your objectivity with that
gentleman
who you said
after the appropriate evaluations you
said sir you're schizophrenic
and he says
you know he was disappointed in that
because
if you had said you're possessed maybe
he has now found a binary yes no answer
instead he's got to work with
medical science and psychiatric science
on the
this
amorphous cloud that's schizophrenia
that's so hard to work with so now
that's harder to take and so it's easier
to say gosh why can't i just be
a simple answer yep
and that might be the difference between
today and 2000 years ago is that
2000 years ago people might have
accepted an answer whether it was valid
or not who knows but today
people will keep searching until they
find the answer that they want and
they're going to find it from somebody
who's going to tell them what they want
to hear i wonder how many people
have been told with a certainty by a
pastor or priest or somebody that
they're possessed
and because that person was seen as a
person of a lot of influence and power
in their lives that they bought into
that
you know like like like i would love to
do a test here's a test
i would love to and and obviously we
can't do this case study because nobody
would sign up for this
but if we were to take
10 kids
okay
and they go to two different schools
okay and one school of thought we would
never do this test but i wonder what the
results for this would be one school
says devil exists and most of you guys
are most likely possessed
and says that to them over and over and
over again
in that school that they're going to
fast forward 10 years later 20 years
later to see what kind of life they live
then the other tank is to go to a
different school and the leader at that
place says
you're protected by god you guys are
meant to do something big with your life
god's going to use you to do something
very special with your life you're
protected everything's going to be all
right
work on yourself work on improving
yourself contribute to society
lead control your imagination fast
forward 20 years later
i wonder what the consequences of those
10 kids on each side is going to be
okay
one side how many of them are actually
going to believe their waste to society
and maybe they're possessed and maybe
they're and then the other says no i'm
supposed to do something big with my
life because god's got my back i'm
destined i'm supposed to how that's
going to turn out now somebody may you
know trash that argument and say what
the hell are you talking about
all i'm saying is i believe there's a
lot of power
when people of influence
their words have more power from the
pulpit when they say things and
someone's standing in the audience and
the parents said that's the priest
that's the pastor i think sometimes
people use that power too much and they
hurt people and they hurt him
permanently for a long time and it
messes their mouth up and that that that
upsets me a lot a lot it ups because
i've seen this myself
so for me
if i know there's power in imagination
if i know there's power in positive
words
it's it's more
about trying to get that encouragement
for people to believe
you know
you have control of your life you can do
something with your life rather than
like look at where america's at right
now what is america's biggest deal right
now and this has got nothing to do with
what you're doing but a part of it does
is
america is convinced
that rich people are bad people they're
fully convinced they're rich people are
bad people they're convinced when you
say we got a tax to billionaires
do you know how many billionaires we
have in america 700 and 720 billionaires
in america do you know what their total
net worth is
4.7 trillion dollars if you tax them a
hundred percent
that wouldn't even be anything close to
how much money they printed the last two
years six trillion dollars and you want
to tax the billionaires but because they
say it so many times from the pulpit
people believe the problem in america is
billionaires so what if people from the
pulpit said
the problem is you and i got to do
something with our lives if you can walk
talk speak you speak a language you
understand people you feel
you have a healthy sense you your health
you have the ability to learn and
improve
you can change your life for the better
but that's not the messaging today the
messaging is victim victim victim victim
victims so for me
whatever the final product comes out of
a denomination or a church or a religion
is a byproduct of the leadership at the
top and that's where my challenge is
with the accountability i don't know if
i answered any question or not i just
that's my biggest challenge and i think
you know going back to even adam touched
on
the catholic church his sins had been in
the news
for the last decade you know whether
it's pedophilia whatever
so for me to even go public on these
things i know that i'm throwing my name
out there to constantly be criticized or
to be judged i mean i had someone come
up to me before in a restaurant and they
said well father i have to tell you that
every time i see a priest i see a
pedophile
so again there is that notion that when
you go public about something that an
issue that people may not necessarily
agree on they'll try to attack you from
a different angle
but i'm not afraid of any of that i'd be
the first one to tell you the church
needs to be accountable for her own
sinfulness
see that's a message that i think people
can respect rather than running and
hiding and sweeping things under the rug
you're saying hey listen let me get out
there and
state my case and i'm not trying to say
that well now that the church talks
about exorcism and this is how we're
going to re-exert our influence and
control that we've lost
because of clergy sex abuse
no
i think ultimately even in the midst of
abuse and whatever the church still has
to be authentic to what she's really all
about and that's promoting the gospel
the message of love promoting god
and you know
there would be some people that might
even suggest when you look at the
sinfulness of the church
is it the way that the
the devil is trying to destroy something
from within
so whether you look at
church leadership and how things are
handled and all of that is that a way to
undermine the authority of the church
have any of these priests that have been
accused or even found guilty of
pedophilia said that it was the devil
that possessed them at that time
no but i remember even uh you know pope
benedict even commenting when he was in
office that there were many people that
were ordained priests that never should
have been ordained priest that somehow
they would somehow they were able to
to get in it's like a cancer that
destroys from within
but ultimately we can't lament anything
we have to say
this is our reality now and then how do
we face it
and then facing our own
you know flaws how do we come out even
stronger as a result of that the greater
danger would be just simply to run away
in the face of criticism i think we have
to face our criticism we have to stand
there and we have to take it whatever
ugliness or mud that people want to
sling
we have to take that
what can the church do to reverse this
negative outlook on the church that's
been in the spotlight for the last few
decades
i think the church has to be even more
public in
the old latin phrase maya culpa maya
culpa it's admit it's admitting guilt
not coming up with excuses or whatever
it's simply saying
i own this i own this ugliness
yeah but is that good enough
i think it's a first step
because we can never go back and we
can't undo anything that's been done
but we can own it
and then ultimately all we can do is
move forward and then hopefully the
experience of that ugliness
causes the church to have a different
outlook or view
on the world and its mission
because that's even when it comes to
anything to deal with the demonic
how do we take what the devil is doing
and to turn it around and make something
good come from it
because we can't live in the past we
can't change the past ultimately all we
can do is learn from it and then move
forward
it said that the authenticity of any
apology would be manifest in tomorrow's
behavior
so if you apologize today then hopefully
we see
the church and the servants of the
church and priests of the church
over time tomorrow we see the service
that
we had all hoped it was all about best
thing i ever heard was the following and
we'll wrap up on this the the best thing
i ever heard from a pastor you know when
i was like well what about this and what
about that and what about this person
what about that church and look at what
they're doing and they say listen
if if your relationship with god's gonna
be horizontal you're gonna fail
if it's vertical you'll be fine he won't
let you down but people will let you
down people are always gonna let others
down because we're people no one walks
on water we make mistakes now that's a
royal mistake by the church it's a royal
it's a royal mistake but
you know if you're gonna
lean on a church to
uh do a hundred percent of things right
you will fail my biggest challenge is
when you have that kind of influence
don't use it to
[Music]
impose so much fear to the point where
you're you're
immobilizing people inject more hope
inject more
faith inject more you know you and i can
do special things with our lives and
make a positive impact and
that father of the two girls
i think that person
is the one that needs to be held
accountable at the highest level that
person needs to go to jail you need to
tell everybody in jail here's what he
does to those two daughters
what do you guys want to do to this guy
he's going to get put off he's not he
won't last a week by the way
um so anyways um look folks if you're
listening to this appreciate your
patience with us every once in a while i
have certain topics that i um
that i go into that some of you guys may
say what was this all about not
expecting
a part of the part of me starting this
podcast wasn't because we want to make
money uh this podcast cost us money that
podcast doesn't break even we lose money
on this podcast but we do it because we
i myself i'm interested in some topics
as a person as i'm growing and
you know living my life i want to learn
about certain unanswered questions and i
think today was a
a very qualified guest that was gracious
enough to take the answers to the
questions the pushback you know the the
questions
tom asked or i asked or tyler ask or
adam asking you were
very gracious about it and that says a
lot about you as an individual and how
you represent the church this was a very
good experience having you here
and i i personally appreciate you coming
out i do want to recommend everybody if
you
are watching this and if you learn
anything from it if your thoughts change
opinions change you know good or worse
comment below i'm actually curious to
know what some of you guys thought about
this at the end of it after listening to
the whole thing
and uh if you do want to go a little
further you may want to go order his
book if we can put the link
in the chat box if we can put in the
description if we can put it everywhere
tyler
exorcism the battle against satan and
his demons
uh to order where in this book he
answers the questions of how the church
selects and trains priests for ministry
of exorcism where and how the devil
operates in the world why is it vital
for catholics who live in a vibrant life
life of faith
what to do if you suspect the presence
of demonic in your life and how to fend
off spiritual attack and build a
stronger relationship with god
uh thank you so much for coming out this
was wonderful appreciate you uh gang i'm
not doing a podcast this week i know you
are our guys are doing podcasts this
week we're not doing anything until next
week
but uh we will be back next week for
podcasts both both days next week not no
i don't think we're are we back next
thursday yeah we'll be back next week
for podcasts we have funny how today at
one adam thursday and friday this week
jedediah's got father lampert tomorrow
at 1. so a lot going on this week
with fatherland
by the way did we get some results on
that poll tyler it was 70 30. seven i
believe yeah seven i think we had
eighteen hundred people respond it was
seventy thirty so there you go father
you've got a lot of people in the
audience that wanna hear more okay hey
take care everybody hope you enjoyed it
bye bye bye bye
you